I just want to demonstrate for you by
way of been a couple of examples how to
use chain rule now with exponential
functions not just to prove like stuff
but to actually find some derivatives
find some answers okay so for instance
if i said to you okay let's
differentiate this function okay now i'm
going to drag this out of it a lot of
you will be able to just look at that
and say it but because once you learn
more just like we're differentiating
powers of X you'll be able to look at
that you're saying but that's the answer
it's very straightforward but for now
what I point out is just like here this
chain rule happening here do you see
that there's a function here and a
function there it's a function or a
function okay so in order to do that
properly we're going to do the
substitution so in this case will that
are you incall 2x today so immediately
that gives you a derivative for you in
terms of X and then over here I can just
get rid of the X terms right because I
can we use the substance me okay here
are all my pieces I'm really not going
to change do you want the X I'm going to
quit the chain rule here is my chain of
derivatives okay and i'm just going to
fit them in right what is the derivative
with respect to you consumption
by definition right by definition if you
didn't think differentiate me the power
of that you're just get back right so I
might be you right off the bat do DX is
very simple to campus we just multiply
it by two and now that's tidied up get
rid of the use that we introduced this
is just to eat books you acts are you
may recognize this right now okay so all
I really need to do is differentiate
that thing up there that guy comes out
the front and then the rest of us stays
the same because that's what
Exponential's do so I can generalize
this which otherwise a very very simply
i can say i'm generalizing the way chain
rule looks for Exponential's is exactly
like this if you've got e raised to the
power of some function chamber works
exactly like a difficult namely you
differentiate doesn't the inside
function which the language starts to
break down now because we called it
inside because it seems like the
brackets right but different brackets
anymore but this is always when you know
right so you differentiate that on it
and then then you differentiate the
outer function but hold on the
derivative of e to the power of whatever
is just e to the power of whatever okay
so you just hand back e to the power of
event right that's what change looks
like we're dealing with exponential i
mean you can compare that to the same
chain rule but when you're dealing with
something raised to a power it's the
same deal right you do the inside and
then you do the outer part just the way
you normally which in this case it is
bring the power down and reduce the
power I want so whatever in here in
black these are both and they're
changing but it's the channel for
Exponential's let's trade offer house
all right and in fact as we keep on
going when we get to Lourdes see how he
goes
and we're going to treat functions
there'll be a chain rule for each of
those okay so kind of Spencer